hey everyone welcome to the waterloo
podcast i'm james marshall
and firstly i give a quick shout out to
fortune favors puresport cbd
and manscape for helping bring this
podcast to you and i'll give you a
little bit more detail at the end of
this
prank yes prank we are back with a prank
it's new prank friday
sorry there hasn't been many pranks
going on but it's just been a bit hard
to keep one out a week
but for this prank we go back to to the
back end of super rugby altera
when prank expert reggie goods was
selling shares in his dodgy adult dvd
store
fiesta videos he just signed up chiefs
winger sean stevenson
and sean has since come out and said
that he would have paid the 43 000 to
come on board
so reggie just wanted to see how much
money he could make from this dodgy
dvd store so we needed a good lad who
loves an investment
and that's where riko yowani comes in
hearing from the guys who know rico wow
he's an
absolute lad and he loves a good dvd so
he was the perfect target
so i hope you enjoy the prank if you do
please share it if not all good
hello hey rico it's uh jason maradon
here from maradona investments
hey man hey how are you doing yeah not
too bad
yeah like i said i've got your number of
tj and um yeah i work i work along with
tj for
well basically since 2014. she's on a
number investment yeah
yeah and yes been highly successful um
himself
and the company having my life very good
yeah
so um i've got a thing i want to talk to
you around
um it's a investment opportunity
so tj's jumped on it and um james
parsons and auckland jumped on it and
uh sean stevenson actually um just
jumped on recently
and it's um in fiesta videos have you
heard of festive videos before
what is it though uh fiesta videos
now is it similar to that um cameo
no it's um it's you know back in the day
used to give those video shops um like
united video and blockbuster and all
that oh yeah
yeah right right yeah it's a similar one
but uh more
in our 18 category
so yeah so um yes in that sense
so you know just giving a few numbers
around the investment
so we're looking at a 43k
investment for 40 percent of the
business
oh yeah yeah so um so yeah 40
of the business so our predictions the
numbers we've been um
putting together is you know new
zealand's got five million people
so you know if each each person so
every man woman child brings the dvd
from us at ten dollars
per year so one dvd yeah ten dollars a
year we're looking at a
50 million dollars in our income stream
income stream
yeah and so which means obviously you're
in um 40
how much they get how much does that
give you you reckon uh
better than christmas mate yeah it will
be 20 million dollars
more than you'll be waiting for all
blacks i bet
yeah yeah is this something you might be
interested in
uh yeah bro i've i'd be happy to discuss
further but we're on the way actually
down to wellington
um we leave in like 20 minutes oh
perfect perfect i'm actually basically
yeah so maybe actually catch up for
coffee
i'm pretty pretty gang focused uh going
down but um
probably if you sunday would probably be
the best time to
okay deeper yeah perfect i'll give you
another call on sunday and take it from
there
yeah just one more thing on on this you
know obviously you're going to be one of
the major shareholders in this business
there will be uh you know promotional
activities so
you know obviously we're going to open
our first video store and you have to
attend it
so just you know yeah cut it open and
then you know all the
all the add-on shoppers because they'll
be the video section also they'll do all
those and all the six toys be around so
uh
it'll be good to have you along
so reggie actually didn't call rico on
sunday
and he actually to be honest he still
hasn't called him back but
as we all know rico is a very smart man
and he worked it out pretty much
straight after this phone call that it
was a prank
anyway like i said at the start pure
sport cbd
have now partnered up with what a lad
what an exciting opportunity
which gives you a great opportunity to
try this unreal product with 20
off it is fully certified by the banned
substance control group
so if you're a professional athlete and
you are tested you are safe
you can get in new zealand and pretty
much anywhere you might be listening to
this podcast
and if for some reason that it did get
stuck in customs
pure sport will send you your money back
risk-free so to get the discount order
as usual through puresport
cbd website at the checkout into
waterlab
20 no spaces in the promo code
and enjoy now we also have manscaped on
board
now this offer is only on for one month
giving you 20
off and free shipping on any order on
their website including the discounted
ones so there's massive savings to be
had
manscaped have the best body hair
clippers in the game
you will not cut yourself guaranteed to
get on this awesome discount
just in time for christmas go to
manscape.com into what a lad in capitals
no spaces
in the promo code and enjoy and last but
not least
as always we have fortune favors on
board who have a 15
off discount for all our waterlab
listeners it's heating up now so it's a
great time to load the fridge with some
cold beers or ciders
and chip away throughout the summer to
get the discount go to fortune favors
beer website which is fortune favors dot
bear
and put in what a lad no spaces in the
promo code to enjoy